notez que les sénateurs des deux côtés
de l'hémicycle à gauche comme à droite
ont été très très très nombreux ici au
sénat remet à suivre les discussions
autour de ce projet de loi c'est assez
rare d'avoir autant de sénateurs dans
l'hémicycle souvent elles sont occupées
par des réunions en commissions en par
différentes fonctions mais là ils
avaient tous envie d'être ainsi présent
et d'intervenir sur l'ensemble du texte
voilà on entend la sonnerie de la séance
retentir ça veut dire que cette séance
va reprendre d'ici quelques secondes
elle va être ouverte par le président de
séance jean léonce dupont et comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure delphine on va
effectivement revenir après l'article 2
sur les histoires autour du nom de
famille de paternité vous nous refait
d'un petit point sur ce sujet dès le
film oui effectivement alors les
questions sont nombreuses il y à des
amendements de l'ump sur toutes ces
questions d'état civil quels noms
devront bien porté à les enfants adoptés
dans des couples homosexuels
il ya aussi cette question de la
transcription à l'état civil français
des enfants nés à l'étranger de
gestation pour autrui
tous ces thèmes et bien vont être
abordés ce soir vous l'avais dit dans
cette séance qui est présidé par le
sénateur centriste jean léonce dupont
alors vous m'appreniez bien et qu'il y
aura un vote bloqué effectivement cela
risque d'accélérer un peu les débats
alors tout de suite nous prenons la
direction de l'hémicycle pour écouter
cette séance a tout de suite jeudi 11
avril le soir des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire sur la
proposition de loi portant réforme de la
biologie médicale ac est donnée de cette
communication
pour le cas où le gouvernement
déciderait de provoquer la réunion d'une
commission mixte paritaire chargée de
proposer un texte sur les dispositions
restant en discussion du projet de loi
portant diverses dispositions en matière
d'infrastructures et de services de
transport il va être procédé à la
nomination des membres de cette
commission mixte paritaire
la liste des candidats a été affichée
je n'ai reçu aucune opposition dans le
délai d'une heure prévue par l'article
12 du règlement
en conséquence cette liste est ratifié
je proclame représentants du sénat à
cette éventuelle commission mixte
paritaire pour les titulaires mais sur
raymond vall roland vias jean jacques
filleul michel teston gérard cornu
madame marie hélène des esgaulx monsieur
vincent capo-canellas pour les
suppléants messieurs pierre camani jean
luc fichet madame evelyne didier
mais si ronan dantec jean bizet rémy
pointereau henri tandonnet
cette nomination prendra effet si
monsieur le premier ministre décide de
provoquer la réunion cette commission
mixte paritaire et dès que monsieur le
président du sénat en aura été informé
nous reprenons la suite de la discussion
du projet de loi adopté par l'assemblée
nationale ouvrant le mariage aux couples
de personnes de même sexe dans les
discussions des articles nous sommes
parvenus à l'amendement numéro 2 118
rectifié au sein de l'article et 2 je
rappelle que nous avons cet amendement
qui font l'objet d'une discussion
commune et que deux amendements sont
identiques pour l'amendement 218
rectifié là
il n'est
pas défendu le 250 capte et présenté
matériel continue merci monsieur le
président madame les ministres mes chers
collègues
l'assemblée nationale a adopté un
amendement ayant pour objet d'aligner
entre les filiations par le sang et
adoptive les règles subsidiaire de
dévolution du nom de famille
en cas de désaccord ou d'absence de
choix des parents
les premiers noms de chacun d'eux a
collé dans l'ordre alphabétique seront
dévolus à l'enfant notre commission des
lois a cependant supprimer cette avancée
pourtant les motivations des députés
était légitime elle poursuivait un but
des qualités entre les enfants car à
défaut de choix des parents le maintien
d'une règle d'attribution patronymique
du nom de famille pour les seuls cas de
filiation par le sang est susceptible
d'introduire une rupture d'égalité entre
les couples suivant qu'il s'agisse d'une
filiation par le sang ou adoptive en
effet dans le premier cas c'est le nom
de famille du père qui prévaudra alors
que dans le second le nom sera choisi
dans l'ordre alphabétique arguments
contre cette harmonisation des règles de
dévolution des noms de famille on nous
avance un souci de simplification et
surtout un souci de préserver l'histoire
familiale à travers la généalogie mais
l'histoire n'est pas que masculine les
recherches généalogiques ne se réduise
évidemment pas à la branche paternelle
la branche maternelle participe aussi de
l'histoire familiale
le fait qu'il y ait plusieurs noms ne
devraient pas nuire aux recherches
l'argument avancé dé donc pas
convaincant et nous vous proposons par
cet amendement de revenir à la règle
adoptée par nos collègues députés
merci chers collègues l'amendement 149
rectifiée présentée par monsieur ruquier
merci monsieur le président à ma garde
des sceaux veut un collègue
l'alinéa 3 de l'article 2 prévoit qu'en
cas de désaccord des parents sous le nom
de l'enfant l'un des parents peut le
signaler à l'officier de l'état civil
le cas échéant en naissance de l'enfant
or la relation actuelle ne permet pas de
savoir quel est le délai jusqu'au
qu'elle cette contestation peut être
signalé hélas même entame que cette
possibilité pourrait se faire sans
limitation dans le temps après la
naissance orly mutabilité du nord et la
nécessaire stabilité de l'état civil
requiert de limiter dans le temps là ma
libération de ce désaccord
la modification proposée permet de
limiter la manifestation ne s'était
accord au plus tard le jour de la
déclaration de l'essence ou par la suite
en cas d'établissement simultanée de la
filiation
il s'agit donc d'un amendement de
sécurisation juridique
merci chers collègues l'amendement 93
rectifié bis s'est présentée par
monsieur gérard président le président
madame le garde des sceaux et je suis
pas convaincu du tout par la proposition
de notre rapporteur sur le choix du nom
en cas de désaccord des parents parce
que il n'a pas prévu des hypothèses qui
malheureusement existent qui sont des
hypothèses de vengeance éventuelle de
l'un des parents à l'encontre de l'autre
et oui ça peut exister malheureusement
alors j'avais préparé quelque chose mais
je ne suis pas satisfait non plus parce
que je trouve que c'est nous sommes dans
une situation très compliquée très
difficile et que tout ce qui concerne le
nom est loin d'être parfait et
d'ailleurs la loi que nous avons adoptée
il ya maintenant plus d'une dizaine
d'années est une loi imparfaite et qui
est qu'il ne permet pas de résoudre
correctement les problèmes
dans la continuité historique que tu
aimes tant monsieur suaire même si on
change un certain nombre de concepts
alors je pense que nous allons vers de
grandes difficultés aussi console usage
du non je ne suis pas satisfait de la
mort de bondues rapporteur je suis pas
satisfait non plus de l' amendement que
je dépose c'est la raison pour laquelle
je le retire
mais je tenais à m'exprimer et je
souhaite que dans le droit de la famille
que nous allons avoir à examiner north
pensions aussi le problème du non merci
chers collègues d'amendements 278 été
présentée par monsieur rapporteur au nom
de la commission des lois
tellement de mots rédactionnelle mais
c'est le président qui tombera si
l'amendement présenté par monsieur
mézard est adopté merci
l'amendement 132 rectifié bis s'est
présenté mal à mettre bas ça
il
il est il est défendu
faire
il est défendu le 177 rectifié bis et
présenté par madame morin desailly par
monsieur roche tout le monde est pas
endormi bon si vous en êtes d'accord
cette présentation aux draps pour
l'amendement 175 et pour le mandement
276 puisqu'il s'agit de dispositifs
similaires
avec cet amendement nous souhaitons
réaffirmer notre position formelle à
toute disposition qui contribuerait à la
concentration des longues sur les 13
premières lettres de l'alphabet le
dispositif que nous proposons serait que
l'ordre des noms soit déterminé par
tirage au sort plutôt que de se référer
au graff avait tic comme le prévoit
actuellement le texte je vous remercie
de votre attention
merci chers collègues
alors monsieur rapporteur quel est
l'avis de la commission merci monsieur
le président le la commission règne un
avis défavorable à l'amendement de 150 4
2 du groupe se soucier du groupe
communiste qui en effet revient au
système de l'assemblée dont je vous ai
exposé tout à l'heure que nous avions
trouvé un système plus je dirais logique
et qui reprend le nom du père dans la
craie en mesure était des caps donc
défavorable de 1 54 par contre favorable
offrant 40 de rectifier qui permet de
bien préciser les cas et comment le
les époux pourront faire connaître leur
absence d'accord par contre alors retiré
le mien mesures présentées
rédactionnelle il tombera si celui de
monsieur mesa est adopté madame lipietz
il est défendu
madame lipiec elle au lieu de prendre le
nom et s'est dit on va tirer au sort bon
la commission a trouvé que pour le nom
de famille tirés au sort vraiment déjà
que le système proposé peut prêter à
certaines interrogations dans cette de
patrice gélard le tirage au sort paraît
encore pire quand le mouvement qui était
présentée par monsieur zocchetto alors
c'est dommage que monsieur zocchetto
aller pour présenter lui-même parce que
cet amendement conscience véritable
ombre zocchetto par un z
on comprend le monsieur zocchetto
veulent que les aides continue à exister
et donc
et voilà donc constamment également
madame la ministre
quel est l'avis du gouvernement mais
chez le président concernant les aides
je n'ai que quelques rares souvenirs de
les enseignements sur le latin le grec
que j'ai eue au lycée je me souviens
d'un magnifique film de costa-gavras et
les uns signifie les vivants et c'est un
film absolument splendide que j'ai vu
oui oui absolument
oui j'étais étudiante il ya longtemps il
ya très longtemps même avis sur les
amendements tout en entendant les
arguments de votre amendement
madame la sénatrice parce que je crois
qu'il faut rappeler effectivement que
l'histoire n'est pas que masculine
donc ce sont des arguments que j'entends
je pense qu'il faut qu'on parvienne
vraiment installé ce débat dans la
société à l'approfondir et à faire que
en se l'approprient de façon à arriver à
changer d'une certaine façon a changé
d'époque sur la question du nom donc
plutôt que de revenir la rédaction de
l'assemblée nationale qui avait décompté
stable défaut mais en insistant sur le
fait qu' on ne règle pas le problème
définitivement parce que il est injuste
et d'une certaine façon pardon à ce que
cela peut blesser un peu mais un peu
archaïque de s'approcher au nom
patronymique
ainsi déterminer j'entends les arguments
mais je pense que la réaction de la
commission des lois est quand même
meilleure que celle du texte sorti de
l'assemblée nationale dans cette unique
réseau le gouvernement émet un avis
défavorable
monsieur le sénateur ok par contre votre
amendement introduit des éléments de
précision est très très intéressant
aussi pour l'officier d'état civil qu'il
convient de déchargé de la
responsabilité de conserver
l'information sur le désaccord
donc le fait de m'être délais et de le
concevoir ainsi améliore réellement le
texte donc le gouvernement émet un avis
favorable sur votre amendement merci
madame la ministre
alors nous votons sur le 254 pas de
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter veuille bien levé
la main merci que ceux qui sont contre
veuille bien levé la main il n'est pas
adopté l'amendement 149 rectifié pas de
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter veuille bien levé
la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre veuille
bien levé la main l'amendement est
adopté le 2 178 tombe le centre honteux
de rectifier bis pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter veut bien levé la
main merci que ceux qui sont contre
veuille bien levé la main l'amendement
n'est pas adopté enfin le 177 rectifié
bis à demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter veuille
bien levé la main mais que ceux qui sont
contre veuille bien levé la main vous
êtes sûr
alors
l'amendement n'est pas adopté nous avons
cinq amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune
l'amendement 65 rectifié lycée présentée
par monsieur jodar
merci monsieur le président si vous
voulez bien je vais présenter 65
rectifié beast 66 rectifié beast et le
76 rectifié bis absolument
alors l'ensemble de ces amendements
concernent naturellement le nom mais ils
sont la conséquence logique de notre
position antérieure en ce qui concerne
le refus de modifier les règles
applicables en matière d'adoption
plénière
comme nous sommes hostiles à cette
modification
nous le sommes autant en matière de
transmission du nom et c'est l'objet de
l'amendement 65 rectifié bis danser
alinéa 6 à 13
de même nous avons un amendement qui
complète le précédent d'amendements 66
rectifié bis qui fait que comme nous
sommes opposés aux modifications des
règles applicables en matière de sion
plénière et que nous sommes également
matière de transmission de noms nous
avons remplacé les 5 alinéa qui était
supprimée par nos par cinq autres alinéa
qui le remplace et qui fait que nous
précisons bien comment nous entendons
transférer le nom de l'adoptant à
l'enfant enfin le dernier alinéa le
dernier amendement le 67 rectifié bis
c'est le problème justement de sauver
certains noms de faire en sorte que le
juge puisse intervenir dans l'intérêt de
l'enfant et faire en sorte qu'ils
puissent inverser le cas échéant
l'ordre dans lequel on avait choisi les
non merci
276 était donc présenté le 94 rectifié
miss c'est encore patrice gélard
ah excusez moi les auteurs de cet
amendement dont le poids même souhaite
éviter qu'on adopte en sol dans le cas
où ils auraient adopté conjointement un
enfant puisse demander seul au tribunal
de modifier les prénoms de l'enfant à
adopter
ne souhaitant qu' il y ait dans ces cas
là les deux parents qui interviennent
merci chers collègues 1 pour le dos en 2
176 il est donc tombé je demande à
monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de la
commission
merci monsieur le président la
commission a émis un avis défavorable
aux deux premiers amendements de
monsieur g là le soir en mairie rectifié
236 puisqu'ils vont la conséquence
logique de la position de monsieur
gérard à l'adoption par les couples
mariés de même sexe sur le 67 rectifié
peas qui dit que le juge peut inverser
l'ordre dans l'intérêt des enfants
la commission a émis un avis favorable
mais à titre personnel je donne un avis
défavorable en effet ce dispositif de
panne est pas nécessaire parce qu'en cas
d'adoption conjointe l'absence de
déclaration qu'on voit des parents est
l'exception
puisqu'ils sont tous les deux partis au
jugement d'adoption et donc on peut
penser qu'ils n'ont pas être en
désaccord à ce moment là sur la façon
dont le nom sera donné à l'enfant
donc la commission et demi à 1 min
favorable à titre personnel j suis
défavorable à l'amendement de ses hôtes
et aux tombes
l'amendement numéro 2 de monsieur gérard
at-il perdu et je suis défavorable parce
qu'il me paraît superfétatoire
il est évident que la précision proposé
va de soi les adoptants sont par
définition des gens mariés donc il
paraît inutile de le préciser mais bon
monsieur hainard le souhaitent
avis favorable de la commission des
favorable du rapporteur
le 219,5 appelé donc voilà madame la
ministre quel est l'avis du gouvernement
ce président un avis défavorable sur
tous ses amendements
le doyen gélard a le mérite de continuer
jusqu'au terme de la discussion de ce
texte sur sa prise de position initiale
concernant l'ouverture du mariage et de
l'adoption
nous avons aussi le mérite de tirer
toutes les conséquences de l'adoption de
l'article 1er est par conséquent tout en
saluant cette cohérence et cette
constance nous émettons un avis
défavorable
merci madame ministre alors nous sommes
sur le 65 rectifié bij et une demande de
part de l'explication de vote de
monsieur sido oui merci monsieur le
président madame la garde des sceaux
chers collègues j'ai deux choses à dire
la première c'est que au fond on
monsieur le rapporteur dis souvent je
suis pas d'accord sans donner
d'explication d'argumentation nous
trouve ça particulièrement déplorable
moi j'étais souvent rapporteur sera un
certain nombre de textes et je m'échine
est expliqué la position de la
commission ce qui m'amène au deuxième
point que je voulais aborder et ça ne
date pas de cet instant j'ai remarqué
cet après midi comme mes collègues
d'ailleurs que vous mais l'envié trop
souvent votre position à vous par
rapport à la position de la commission
monsieur le président c'est inadmissible
que monsieur le rapporteur s'exprime en
fonction de la décision de la commission
c'est très bien maintenant si il
s'exprime en son nom il change de place
mais il faut pas mélanger les genres et
j'ai remarqué je vais plus loin qu'ils
passent plus de temps à expliquer sa
position personnelle que la position de
la commission
ça n'est pas admissible
merci j'ai un collègue monsieur le
président de la commission monsieur sido
je souhaite vraiment répondre à votre
intervention
parce que premièrement monsieur jean
pierre michel a rendu contre
scrupuleusement pour tous les
amendements pour tous les amendements de
la position de la commission
deuxièmement il est monsieur sido de
tradition constante
ici comme à l'assemblée nationale que
lorsque le rapporteur n'est pas en
accord avec la position majoritaire de
la commission il peut exprimer son sa
position personnelle cela existe depuis
toujours et monsieur michel à exercer ce
droit avec beaucoup de modération
ensuite je pense qu'il faut faire très
attention monsieur sido parce qu'il
arrive aussi quelquefois que certains
présidents de commissions s'exprime à
cette tribune en faisant de la première
ligne à la dernière un discours qui
pourrait être celui du porte-parole de
leur groupe
chacun chacun s'exprime comme il le veut
nous n'avons pas nous n'avons pas fait
de remarques jusqu'à ce jour
à cet égard il peut arriver d'ailleurs
que lorsque l'on parle au bois en tant
que président de commission
on défend quelquefois les choses avec sa
personnalité mais je tiens à dire quand
même parce que chacun peut
le constater qu'il y a une grande
honnêteté intégrité rigueur dans la
manière dont monsieur jean-pierre michel
accompli sa mission d'animation otayo
pour explication de vote
simplement un mot je dirai rien vraiment
sur la porter simplement le président de
la commission un présent la commission
vient de mettre en cause un autre
résident d'une autre commission
mystérieusement d'ailleurs
mystérieusement donc tous les cols tous
les présidents de commissions ne sont
pas là mais tous les prix dans deux
collisions sont pas là donc si vous avez
des noms à mettre en cause des prisons
de commissions faites le au moins en
leur présence ça nous permettra d'abord
ça nous permettra d'une part de voir qui
vous visent et si ça leur permettra
ensuite de pouvoir répondre à vous
atypique monsieur le président merci
cher collègue monsieur le leurs
explications de vote
merci monsieur le président madame nos
ministres du chers collègues je vois
très bien entendu compte sept articles
ou deux pour deux raisons
la première est une raison de fond
puisque le projet de loi est portée par
une volonté politique qui nous dit que
on conquiert une nouvelle liberté pour
les couples de même sexe
sans rien enlever aux autres or dans cet
article nous changeons complètement là
le passage de deux noms de généalogie de
transmission du nom pour les couples de
même sexe mais également pour tout le
monde et là il y à un changement qui
peut ne pas satisfaire aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des couples de même sexe
donc ça c'est une première première
raison la deuxième ah ouais mais c'est
une des raisons
moi je n'ai pas forcément envie de
modifier cette façon de faire que nous
avons depuis des millénaires
le deuxième point que je voulais évoquer
c'est le fait que désormais on inverse
les choses il n'ya plus comme avant la
transmission du nom paternel sauf
volonté des deux paroles aujourd'hui
automatiquement sauf inversion c'est le
nom a doublé du père fin des deux
parents qui va porte que va porter
l'enfant et il va le porter dans l'ordre
alphabétique
alors je m'interroge évidemment s'il n'y
a pas à contrer par an au bout de
combien de générations
nous n'aurons plus que des noms de
famille qui commence par a et b la
question est posée
merci chers collègues je n'ai pas
d'autre demande monsieur le pic du camp
nou j'ai pas vu beaucoup de temps
jusqu'à maintenant mais c'est le
président met la min ce moi je suis un
peu inquiet je réside à l'étranger
depuis 40 ans et choix pas discuter de
la loi mais justement sous le principe
des noms en sciences elle est non est-ce
qu'on a réfléchi chose que oui est-ce
qu'on a réfléchi à ce qui va se passer
avec des noms de franco espagnol franco
brésilien et autres qui ont qui ont des
noms très compliqué très long et qui
s'ajoute famille et vous le savez les
grands-parents et lorsqu'il s'agit de
franco brésilien il ya un an français
qui s'ajoute déjà un nom brésilien est
alors lorsqu'il y aura un couple avec
les noms à la paire mais rendent
alphabétique et cetera est ce que vous
avez réfléchi à ce que vont à ce à quoi
vous représentez et non merci chers
collègues n'a pas relevé monsieur quand
dubois explications de vote
oui monsieur le président moi je
voudrais abondé dans le sens des
observations de bruno sido
c'est vrai qu'il est quand même pas
courant que la commission et le
rapporteur soit deux d'avis différents
alors j'ai entendu le président de la
commission mais moi naïvement je pensais
que la commission dont on peut penser
qu'elle est majoritaire et qu'elles
puissent suivre le rapporteur je ne
comprends pas naïvement pourquoi le
rapporteur peut être en contradiction
avec la commission et pourtant j'ai
écouté les explications du président de
la commission
mais comme c'est quand même pas banal je
vous jure j'ai encore envie d'entendre à
la fois le rapporteur est le président
de la commission parce que c'est un
événement
un rapporteur qui sont en contradiction
avec la commission qui est normalement
sens est majoritaire et suivre le
rapporteur c'est pas banal dans cet
hémicycle et moi je voudrais encore
avoir des explications complémentaires
merci chers collègues la part et à
monsieur le rapporteur et non mais bon
si vous pensez mes chers collègues que
j'ai fait trop et atteindre le vie
personnelle j'en ferai moins état dans
les deux trois amendements qui reste
pour le reste les exemples sont
fréquents et je parle sous le contrôle
du mal de la présidente d' inique
lorsqu'elle présidait la commission des
affaires sociales et de la loi
bioéthique
rappelez-vous le psychodrame on a dû
changer de rapporteur en cours de
discussion et monsieur laurin est ce un
bon et quand même quelques souvenirs par
la même chose mais il disait ici
la commission était pour cet amendement
à titre personnel je suis contre voilà
et tout le débat s'est déroulé comme ça
et on a rien dit voilà donc là c'est
vraiment et là c'est vraiment très
résiduel très ému
merci mais non excusez moi c'est la loi
sur la psychiatrie
merci monsieur le président la
commission je voulais simplement dire à
nos collègues avant notre collègue que
je m'étonne de la conception qu'il se
fait du travail parlementaire
il est arrivé il arrive presque chaque
semaine dans la commission des lois mais
comment d'autres commissions que la
commission sur tel ou tel amendement ne
suivent pas le rapporteur heureusement
que ça arrive
nous ne sommes pas des mécaniques nous
mais c'est très important
nous sommes là pour travailler et il ya
souvent des votes des partages et c'est
ce qui donne tout son intérêt au travail
parlementaire mon cher collègue d'autres
pas d'autres demandes d'explications de
vote que ceux qui souhaitent adopter cet
amendement veut bien levé la main le 65
rectifié bis
merci que ceux qui sont contre va bien
levé la main l'amendement n'est pas
adoptée sur le 66 rectifié biz pas de
demandes d'explications de vote même
vote même vote sur le 67 rectifié biz
pas de demandes d'explications de vote
même vote même vote sur le 94 rectifié
bis pas de demandes d'explications de
vote même vote même vote sont arrivés à
l'amendement 219 rectifier il n'est pas
soutenu et nous votons donc tous deux
ont voté sur l'article 2 et je les
demandes d'explications de vote
oui madame sittler la bruyère
le site
cornu monsieur le président madame la
garde des sceaux
mes chers collègues le présent article
qui traite du nom de l'enfant est
intéressant car il illustre
l'impréparation qui a présidé à la
rédaction du projet de loi dans son
ensemble et les risques non mesuré qu'il
fait porter sur le mariage et la famille
on nous dit que le mariage pour tous
n'entraînera pas de transformation de
l'institution du mariage
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui or
force est de constater que nos collègues
députés se sont rendus compte que la
règle actuelle constitue constit ans
consistant à donner à l'enfant le nom du
père ne sera nullement applicable
couples de même sexe
ils ont donc proposé de changer cette
règle pour tous portant atteinte au
mariage conscient de cette difficulté
notre commission des lois nous propose
maintenant un double système on
maintient la règle en vigueur pour les
couples hétérosexuels et un autre
système pour les couples homosexuels
même si la majorité gouvernementale
tente de s'en défendre
c'est bien un mariage à deux têtes qu'on
nous propose ici
cela prouve bien que l'institution du
mariage n'est nullement adapté à la
distinction couples hétérosexuels
couples homosexuels car leur situation
ne sont pas équivalentes
c'est pourquoi il m'est impossible de
voter une telle disposition collègues
la parole est un monsieur de lège pour
explication de vote
le président mesdames les ministres
collègues
vous conviendrez je pense avec moi que
l'enfant en principe participe d'un
projet parental et familiale et que par
conséquent on peut déjà formé un voeu
c'est que toutes les dispositions dont
on vienne débattre ne se traduisent pas
dans les fêtes trop souvent mais reste
quelque chose d'exceptionnel j'avoue
j'ai du mal à comprendre que l'on puisse
avoir des conflits sur la transmission
du nom au moment même où l'enfant entre
dans la famille et j'avoue que ce débat
fait écho chez moi à l' annonce faite
par le président de la république il ya
quelques jours appelant un choc de
simplification j'avoue que je ne vois
pas dans ce texte
en quoi ils participent de ce souhait de
simplification j'ai plutôt le sentiment
que nous allons en sens inverse et se
débat et ce texte montre aussi que
contrairement à ce qui a été affirmé
ce texte n'est pas neutre pour les
familles hétérosexuelles et tant s'en
faut
je voudrais dire aussi que le débat que
nous venons d'avoir autour du nom
si on considère que le nom c'est
reconnaître l'autre la transmission du
nom de famille avec tout ce que j'ai
entendu et ce que vous vous apprêtez
sans doute à voter entre pour le moins
que votre conception de la famille
n'est pas tout à fait la même que la
nôtre
effectivement et que vous avez du mal
madame le ministre de la famille a nommé
la famille est à dire ce qu'est pour
vous la famille car effectivement le nom
de famille aujourd'hui ce n'est pas très
clair merci chers collègues
la parole est un monsieur cornu pour
explication de vote
oui monsieur le président monsieur
mesdames madame la ministre monsieur
rapporteur chars collègue m'a écouté
comme beaucoup de mes collègues mais ça
bosse surprendra pas considère que cette
réforme qui consiste à rendre express la
déclaration d'attribution du nom du père
à défaut de quoi le nom des deux parents
seront transmis à leurs enfants portent
atteinte à la lisibilité généalogique
qui permet à chacun de s'inscrire dans
une histoire de familiale cohérente et
c'est vrai comme l'a dit très justement
mon collègue comme simplification on a
pas mieux
en effet cette modification fragilise
d'autant plus la présomption de
paternité puisque elle entraînera une
généralisation importante des noms
double avec un tel dispositif nous
obligions donc les parents à procéder de
génération en génération
un choix permanent alors que les
familles sont pour la plupart des passes
et déjà par les nombreuses démarches
administratives qui font suite à la
naissance de leur enfant
ainsi je crois que c'est une atteinte
non négligeable au droit de chacun
d'accéder à ses origines c'est tout
simplement scandaleux
les français ont manifesté massivement à
ce sujet il reste particulièrement
attaché à ce dispositif et c'est
probablement la raison pour laquelle
ils n'ont eu que très rarement recours
au dispositif qui permet déjà de
transmettre à son enfant des noms double
depuis 2002 nous ne comprenons pas
pourquoi ce dispositif qui ne concerne
que les couples de même sexe soient
applicables à tous les couples mariés
alors je comprends bien qu'il soit
impossible de sortir de l'impasse du
défaut de choix lorsque les coûts sont
de même sexe mais est ce une raison pour
imposer un dispositif qui ne concerne
que les couples de même sexe à toutes
les familles françaises
alors je sais que madame la ministre
nous dit qu'il est question de mettre
tout le monde sur le même pied d'égalité
l'égalité encore et toujours
je voudrais toutefois rappeler à madame
la ministre qui ne s'agit pas d'égalité
puisque les parents ont bel et bien le
choix si les couples homosexuels veulent
transmettre un nom en particulier ils le
peuvent
certes on ne doit pas laisser les textes
un taux instaurer des zones d'ombré il
est vrai mais dans ce cas peut-être
pourrions-nous laisser la navette
améliorer ce dispositif en prévoyant une
règle particulière pour les couples de
même sexe
très honnêtement nous ne pouvons pas
laisser les choses telles qu'elles sont
parce que nous verrons par erreur ou par
dépit la disparition progressive de la
seule transmission du patronyme qui
constitue aujourd'hui la réalisation
concrète de la présomption de paternité
ainsi nous aurions préféré que le
dispositif actuellement en vigueur reste
applicable non pas par convenance par
rapport à un sexe en particulier ou un
type d'union mais parce que la
transmission du nom paternel permet
aujourd'hui et depuis plusieurs siècles
d'établir une généalogie claire et l'isi
bhl en consacrant concrètement pour tous
les pères de famille
la présomption de paternité le lien
paternel étant beaucoup plus difficiles
à établir que celui que la mère établie
avec son enfant vous l'imaginez bien
donc la naissance d'un enfant étant un
moment fort dans la vie de chaque parent
je demande au gouvernement de ne pas les
assommer par des procédures
administratives qui sont déjà très
nombreuses
enfin cela nous évitera par ailleurs des
coûts administratifs importants car vous
imaginez bien que l'ensemble des deux
communes à une strate if
ne sont pas adaptés un tel dispositif
avec ce projet il va donc falloir les
modifier un art c'est ça la
simplification que monsieur le président
nous appelle de ses voeux
bien sûr quel coût pour l'administration
qui a déjà bien du mal à faire face et
la rigueur de la crise
vous imaginez en fait on veut tout et
son contraire
ainsi et parce que cette réforme porte
atteinte à la famille et par ce cas là
elle est illisible et coûteuse
nous ne pouvons pas l'adopter en l'état
merci chers collègues
la parole est à manama la parole est à
madame de roche pour explication de vote
merci monsieur le président maintenant
med
non madame la ministre mes chers
collègues l'article dans à réécrire
l'article 311 21 du code civil qui
précise les règles de dévolution des
notes faible et je ne vois pas cette
obsession du progrès et de la modernité
que qui vous atteint pour cette
attribution du nom de famille que dit
l'article arctique dit que l'article 311
21 du code civil dit que spontanément
les couples qui n'ont font pas de
déclaration conjointe comme c'est le cas
dans la majeure partie des dca verront
leurs enfants prendre le nom du père ce
qui n'empêche pas les parents de donner
à leurs enfants le nom de la mère ou les
deux noms mais le problème c'est que cet
article dans l'état actuel de sa
rédaction n'impose rien à personne il
est justement en adéquation avec la
réalité de notre pays et les pratiques
majoritaire qui s'y développent donné
par défaut le nom du père ce n'est pas
un passage en force n'est pas
méconnaître la société
ce n'est pas forcé les français à
adopter un comportement puis ce qu'ils
adhèrent massivement à cette pratique
et vous vous en rendrez compte si vous
faites adopter ces ces mauvaises
dispositions les français ne
comprendront pas immédiatement un
changement il est très possible que de
nombreuses demandes de corrections
ultérieure interviennent après
l'adoption de telles mesures
et après cela vous rendrez compte que
les français sont attachés à la
transmission à l'enfant du nom du père
alors non pas non pas pour montrer la
supériorité du père sur la mer où une
plus grande autorité mais tout
simplement pour marquer la filiation
je pense qu'il faut cesser de voir de la
domination masculine et c'est une femme
qu'il dit là où il n'y en a pas cette
pratique une pratique culturelle qui
peut donc varier d'un pays à l'autre et
en tant que femme je pense que lier le
système de dévolution du nom alors on a
quelques instants à cette sens pour
faire un petit bilan d'étape on va dire
avec michel meunier la rapporteure pour
avis de la commission des affaires
sociales alors les articles 1 et 2 du
projet de loi ont été adoptés c'est
quand même les articles les plus
importants puisque il ouvre à la fois le
mariage pour les couples homosexuels
mais également l'adoption
les débats ont été très longs sur ces
deux premiers articles est-ce que vous
pensez que maintenant les choses vont un
petit peu s'accélérer ici au sénat sur
le restant des amendements et des
articles on le pensait je le pensais
aussi que les choses allaient
s'accélérer
or en fait là sur l'article 3 qui
concerne les prénoms on assiste aussi
encore et toujours à de très nombreuses
prises de parole sur article les
explications de vote systématique
c'est de bonne guerre finalement
l'opposition la droite bataille pas mal
article par article amendement par
amendement sur ce texte
tout à fait amendement par amendement il
y a facilement 5 6 voire plus prise de
parole donc c'est pesant parce qu'on se
demande quelle stratégie fin on la
devine bien sûr reims et devait retarder
le vote de cette loi
oui et puis en même temps on entend les
prises de position dans l'hémicycle des
uns et des autres qui vont parfois au
delà des prises de position politiques
et des vraies convictions d'un côté
comme de l'autre qui s'expriment comment
vous vous trouvez la tonalité générale
de ce débat depuis jeudi dernier
je pense que les choses se passent de la
même manière sur le fond qu'à
l'assemblée nationale la forme est
peut-être un peu plus feutrée ou plus
contenue mais les arguments sont de même
nature et la violence de certains propos
est très troublante en tout cas moi je
pense qu'il y à autant de violence et de
discrimination
encore une fois peut être dit avec des
formes mais le fond est quand même assez
dominé par du rejet
de ce projet de texte et des personnes
de même sexe oui il ya eu des
propositions et des interventions au
ciel assez violente du côté de la gauche
je pense par exemple à pierre laurent en
début de semaine qui est arrivé dans
l'hémicycle en stigmatisant un peu les
opposants au projet de loi en les
traitant d' homo fox n'a pas été très
bien vécu ici au sénat sur les bancs la
droite comme sur certains bons à gauche
aussi sur les bords socialiste je pense
et vous en conviendrez que nous somme
très raisonnable que l'on se fait
vraiment force de ne pas réagir parce
qu'ils attendent ça peut être aussi des
réactions de notre part et nous sommes
trading je trouve que les collègues
sénateurs et sénatrices prennent
beaucoup sur eux pour ne pas réagir
merci beaucoup à michel meunier je vais
vous laisser rejoindre l'hémicycle du
sénat pour la suite de cette c'est en ce
qu'on va continuer à suivre en direct
sur public sénat ont rejoint tout de
suite l'hémicycle avec le sénateur ump
françois noël buffet qui est enfant doit
encore un exemple de la complémentarité
entre un homme et une femme bien sûr
plus intéressant aussi la psychanalyste
geneviève delaisi dira d'ailleurs ceci
je la cite un lors du vote de la loi de
2002 j'étais plutôt pour que la mère
puisse donner son nom à l'enfant je
pense qu'il y avait un intérêt à sortir
de cet éternel dichotomie je pensais
qu'ils aient parents le symbolique pour
le père et le charnel pour la mer
aujourd'hui je serais plus nuancé non
les sexes ne sont pas égaux en matière
de prothèses de procréation la tradition
prati linéaire et peut-être ringarde
mais quoi qu'on y fasse les femmes
portent les enfants et pas les hommes en
attendant le jour où l'on mettra au
monde des enfants sans l'utérus de leur
mère il est important que l'enfant garde
le nom de son père
justement à cause de cette inégalité
fondamentale alors que tous les repères
familiaux explose de nom reste l'un des
éléments forts de paternité
celle ci est temps de plus en plus
fragile il faut conserver ce repère là
parce que nous vivons dans une société
qui en a énormément besoin 10 et elle
est je le rappelle au moment de la loi
de 2002
l'importance de cette symbolique est si
forte qu'aujourd'hui moins de 5% des
femmes non mariées attribue encore à
leurs enfants
le nom du père et dans le cas contraire
ne le
pas parce que dans plus de 9 cas sur 10
le père ne reconnaît pas l'enfant
nous ne sommes pas psychanalyste en tous
les cas pour ce qui me concerne c'est
évident mais nous devons dire que nous
pouvons adhérer à cette analyse plus
largement il faut penser que la
généralisation des noms double telle
qu'elle est organisée par le présent
dispositif va affaiblir la présomption
de paternité ce que nous cessons de dire
depuis maintenant plusieurs heures mais
plus encore cela va complexifier
l'établissement de la généalogie de
chacun et faire de la recherche de nos
origines
une véritable course d'obstacles
évidemment c'est parce que nous
souhaitons ainsi pour toutes les raisons
que je viens d'évoquer j'aurais préféré
que le dispositif actuellement vigueur
restent applicables
je ne crois pas d'ailleurs qu'en disant
cela je me range du côté d'une société
dite patriarcale nous savons tous plus
que personne plus que plus personne
parle on ne raisonne ainsi sauf
peut-être effectivement quelques
fanatiques
alors si je souhaite que les règles de
la transmission du nom privilégient
encore le long du père c'est pour que
l'on ait encore les moyens d'établir une
généalogie claire lisible en consacrant
concrètement pour tous les pères de
famille la présomption de paternité le
lien partenaires étant beaucoup plus
difficiles à établir que celui que la
mère établie évidemment avec son enfant
madame le garde des sceaux madame le
ministre sur les propos que je ne viens
de tenir qui ne sont pas évidemment des
propos polémiques mais je pense que vous
êtes occupé à d'autres fins merci madame
le garde des sceaux pour l'attention que
vous portez aux parlementaires j'aurai
l'occasion d'ailleurs dans d'autres
circonstances demain d'attirer votre
attention sur un autre sujet qui ne
concernent pas ce texte et pour lequel
vous n'avez pas daigné non plus donné de
réponse sur un sujet qui viendra en
séance dans quelques semaines et avec
lequel nous n'avons pas eu beaucoup de
difficultés avec le fonctionnement de
votre cabinet je vous remercie de ne pas
m'avoir écouté
la parole est un monsieur sido pour
explication de vote
écoutez nous le trouvons monsieur le
président madame la garde des sceaux qui
m'écoutent pas dans une situation
absolument caricatural on voit bien
l'état d'impréparation de ce texte qui
nous est proposé qui nous est soumis je
n'en veux pour preuve que la loi devient
bavarde
ce qui est très mauvais signe et que
monsieur le rapporteur n'était pas très
satisfait que son amendement
pas plus que le doyen notre doyen gélard
et qu'il a retirés mais il n'y est pour
rien le doyen gélard ce n'est pas son
texte il a essayé de sauver les meubles
et faire de ce qu'ils pouvaient et
finalement il s'est aperçu qu'ils ne
pouvaient rien et donc on voit bien que
la situation est grave à cet instant
parce que sur un sujet aussi important
monsieur le président que la
transmission du nom que sur les lignées
familiales
on ne peut pas comme ça sur un coin de
table
rédiger un texte d'ailleurs qui ont été
décidés à temps avant d'avoir été
réfléchie bref le gouvernement actuel ne
sait et on le voit bien sur beaucoup de
sujets mais je voudrais rester à notre
sujet que le gouvernement actuel ne sais
que tout compliquer tout en mêlée et
finalement le tout gratuitement
alors on ne s'étonnera pas dans ces
conditions monsieur le président madame
la ministre que nos concitoyens soient
désorienté protestent et finalement soit
poussé vers les extrêmes
ce texte a été rédigé dans la
précipitation
c'est un texte idéologique le code civil
est ébranlé ce temple
quand même ce temple des lois de la loi
le code civil ne ressemble à cette
heure-ci plus à rien alors moi ce que je
pense qu'il est impossible de voter et
ce n'est pas une constatation politique
et c'est pourquoi j'invite mes collègues
à ne pas voter cet article 2 parce que
il met la pagaille partout merci merci
chers collègues
la parole est un monsieur richard pour
explication de vote
un rappel au règlement
excusez mon cher collègue rappel au
règlement de monsieur x men oui merci
monsieur le président nos collègues vous
écoute avec calme tranquillité qui
études lire des fiches quand vous
distribuer et qui au gré de ce qu'on
vous a écrit vous font au gré de ce que
vous a écrit ou font varier dans vos
interventions
tantôt sur un mode tranquille tantôt
agressif je me demande un moment si vous
portez ou si vous sentez le ridicule qui
peut s'abattre sur vos interventions
alors je le fais je le fais
tranquillement parce que vous êtes vous
êtes avec votre vous êtes avec votre
conscience de parlementaires que je
respecte
c'est uniquement pour moi l'occasion de
rappeler et vous pouvez reprendre la
parole derrière gagner encore quelques
minutes ça ne changera rien notre
détermination
ce que je veux vous dire c'est que nous
sommes déterminés nous sommes déterminés
à vous écouter tranquillement d'éditer
les propos qu'on vous écris pouvoir
distribuer les feuilles les uns et les
autres et puis reprendre des articles
alors cette intervention avait pour but
de dire à mes collègues combien je suis
fier de leur patience de leur
détermination et
de leur présence permanente parce que
cet après midi j'ai entendu une
intervention
cet après midi moi j'ai l'habitude j'ai
l'habitude d'écouter quand on me parle
je vois que vous avez du mal à le faire
vous savez nous on vous écoute on vous
interromps pas mais vous vous n'êtes
même pas capable d'écouter un orateur de
notre groupe
le président du groupe vous parle vous
pourriez au moins avoir le respect et la
politesse d'écouté voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire et je n'en ai pas fini
parce que je vais prendre encore un
petit peu de temps moi aussi ça me fait
du bien pour mes collègues et pour moi
de m'adresser à vous et et de vous dire
sincèrement vous avez à répétition les
mêmes arguments
la ministre les ministres vous ont
répondu les ministres ont répondu mais
nous sommes ici serein déterminé et nous
allons continuer à vous entendre cette
intervention va faire perdre quelques
minutes je m'en excuse
chers collègues mais je la fais en votre
nom
parce que je connais je connais votre
détermination et je sais par moment
votre je cherche le terme lassitude
dirais-je
à entendre les mêmes arguments qui se
répète sans arrêt sans arrêt sans arrêt
et donc si vous vouliez vraiment faire
avancer le débat parlementaire
nous irions au fond des choses mais
c'est impossible puisque vous faites les
les arguments répétition quitte à vous
contredire qui te ne m'en voulez pas des
fois à butée à butée sur les mots que
l'on vous a distribué sur la lecture des
feuilles qu'on vous donne sur la lecture
des feuilles qu'on vous donne est donc
nous vous laissons nous écoutons
continue et que cette intervention vous
permettent de gagner quelques instants
par vos réponses merci
la parole est à monsieur richard iii
explications de vote
la parole est à monsieur longuet pour un
rappel en ramène le président du groupe
socialiste is you sénat on ne lâchera
rien at il dit à l'intention des
sénateurs de l'opposition qui c'est vrai
font durer le débat depuis maintenant
quelques jours font durer un petit peu
le plaisir on va faire un dernier point
avec delphine girard en tribune de
presse
oui perrine 1 et bien on croyait que les
débats s'accélérer et puis en fait la
droite continue de ralentir les débats
elle a trouvé plusieurs moyens a tantôt
elle s'en prenait au rapporteur
jean-pierre michel estimant et bien
qu'il ne donnait pas la position de la
commission des lois mais sa propre
position personnelle maintenant elle
multiplie les explications de vote sur
l'article 2 de ce projet doit qui
concerne la dévolution lé nom de famille
est la tension monte d'un cran ici au
sénat et il faut donc s'attendre à ce
que les débats et bien s'enflammer et
deviennent de plus en plus compliqué sur
ce projet loi ouvrant le mariage aux
personnes de même sexe voilà ce qu'on
pouvait dire que ce soir merci delphine
alors la dernière rumeur qui circule ce
soir ici au sénat eh bien c'est la
rumeur d'un vote bloqué sur tout ou
partie du texte l'article 44-3 de la
constitution que le gouvernement
pourrait mettre en oeuvre c'est un
article très politique et très rarement
utilisé la dernière fois qu'elle a été
utilisée ici au sénat c'était lors du
projet de loi sur les retraites en
général c'est très mal vécue par les
parlementaires mais si la droite fait
durer les débats si ça s'éternise et ici
à la haute assemblée est bien le
gouvernement pourrait avoir recours à ce
vote bloqué donc on refait le point sur
toute cette séance et ses procédures à
partir de demain matin 10h 15 sur notre
antenne merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis et très bonne soirée à tous sens
on